Good morning John.
In 2007, a group of people got together and
we hacked YouTube. There's a lot of ways to
put it but I think that's the simplest. We
used all the tricks that we'd learned as YouTubers
to help our videos get more views, and we
used those tricks more than we would ever
have used those tricks normally. And while
this would have felt underhanded and maybe
even a little bit dirty if we were just doing
it to grow our video views, instead, if felt
awesome because we were doing it for charity.
Unfortunately, Mike Huckabee's attempts to
hack the republican nomination for president
interfered with our taking over the entire
first page of the most discussed page, but
in the end, our hack was more successful than
his.
The project continued annually, although every
year seeming a little bit less subversive,
a little bit less underground and a little
bit more legitimate, and more and more YouTube
actually wanted to work together with us to
promote it. I'm like "YouTube! What's up?
That's not what it's about. You're supposed
to be some faceless monolith that we have
to work through the back doors to get to the
top. You're not supposed to be like 'Hi my
name is Ramia, and this is Margaret and Ben
and Chris and we're all gonna help you get
to the front page of YouTube and you don't
have to subvert us, we want to help'". What
I just realized John, is often the most elegant
hacks have an element of social engineering.
The real con relies on somebody weaseling
their way in the organization so that they
can do stuff from the inside. And let me tell
you, we weaseled our way like no other. We
went from having to use every trick in the
book to get a few more thousand views on YouTube,
to YouTube literally banging down our door
to get involved.
Why is that? Well, I think it's two reasons.
One, because I think everyone wants to help
and they're just looking for a way. Like we
all know that the world is broken but it's
just so hard to figure out how to get involved
without feeling really, just depressed about
the whole thing. People want it to be meaningful
but they don't want to feel bad about it.
They don't want to hate their entire lives
just because they're trying to do something
good and I think that everybody knows that
that's what the Project For Awesome's for.
Really the obvious and real reason why YouTube
wants to be involved in this is because they
see how powerful this community is and how
much more powerful it could be if we all shared
these resources and used the power of our
community and of their platform and mixed
it together for true epicness.
So honestly, what we're doing here, is hacking
for charity harder than ever before. We hacked
WheezyWaiter's chest hair, we hacked John's
fear of heights, and we hacked YouTube from
the inside out. I mean how else could we change
the logo, get 40 front page video features
and have access to a team of YouTube employees
to plan a ridiculously fancy live show.
And yeah, I think next year, we're gonna do
it a little bit differently, but there is
no denying that this has been the most successful
Project For Awesome ever. 600.,000 comments,
on over 3000 Project For Awesome videos with
a total running time of over 40 hours and
total video views of over 10 million. And
whereas previous Project For Awesomes had
been all about raising awareness through creation
of videos, this year, we also raised money.
Over $100,000 in small donations and a total
of over $130,000. That of course meaning that
the vast majority of that money was raised
by small donations from individuals like you.
Thousands of individuals giving what they
can, adding up to a huge, huge number. I think
I'm proud of the Project For Awesome more
than I'm proud of anything else that I've
ever done.
The quality of the videos produced for the
project keeps going up, the total number of
people working on it keeps going up, and I'm
so impressed by the way people work together
cause they want to work together and they,
everyone feels they're sort of equal part
in this thing. And more than anything, I feel
like we are all people being people no matter
where we are or what our circumstances are
which I think has implications way beyond
the Project For Awesome.
Thank you to all of you. Thank you John, and
John, I will see you on Wednesday.
End screen time! There was one video that
didn't get a lot of promotion during the Project
For Awesome because it was uploaded a little
late, but man are you going to weep. Shawn's
Uncultured Project video this year--you should
click and check it out right now.